consigliamo di giocare con un game parla
ascoltati o se vogliono giocare con le
monete di cioccolata al post la tastiera
lo faccia non c'è bisogna che tu mi
venga a dire che cazzo devi usare ok ok
bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
avessero video sono fa vj oggi siamo
trovati su aim ha in breve
l'ultima volta che ci ho giocato l'anno
aggiunto 2 miliardi di cose tipo questa
o una baguette c'è la paghetta perché
l'importante ragazzi non è avere del
pane ma avere una lunga baguette ogni
volta che gioco sta roba non mi ricordo
mai mai come ci si muove un macello ecco
perfetto sembra che alla radio sit rizzi
una baguette è una cosa normale
in realtà lo scopo di sta roba è quello
di spaccare più cose possibili è che ha
organizzato un party con la birra senza
di me bastardi ecco sperimenti allo
scopo è la madonna la baguette la lancio
perché cassano uno scoperto prima suo
gioco su tra eccoci qua perfetto vai
così sono un design tratto non sono
anche è partito un razzo acciaio è vabbè
ora torrazzo ragazzi è stato succede
spacchi grazie a dio ti fa piacere
quando mi dicono che spacco di brutto
grazie ragazzi gravità zero cos'è sta
roba
le hanno inventate tutto e questo
diventa un toast perché se tipo
galleggiando in mezzo allo spazio spiega
non sa cos'è siete seri davvero qualcosa
ma cos'è sta roba che ha mandato va bè
ragazzi e una cucina nello spazio giusto
ma sei serio ma chi ha il gran figata
aerea no ma sei tu sei sta roba
e come si fa ci vado no vabbè regala
l'epicità questo ma come ho fatto a non
scoprirlo prima e il gioco dell'anno
come cazzo al fatto a fa sta cosa c'è
una bottiglia che galleggia un giorno
altissime no mi dispiace mi scusi nebula
1a nebula uno tosto imburrato passo tos
imburrato passo è per caso le formiche
formiche spaziali perda
vabbè mi hanno preso io penso è fermato
a 69 ragazzi 69 non è per caso a 3 o 5
detroit station navicella tosta
tostapane navicella tosta tostapane mi
ricevette navicella tosta tostapane
basso richiedo attracco immediato
vi chiedo traco immediato non davo la
parte [ __ ] manovra di rotazioni in
corso navicella tosta tostapane mi
ricevette passo manovra di rotazione
eseguita no cazzo è vabbè io giocavo a
clash of france mentre facevano le
istruzioni di gay
piano piano una vice la tos che cazzo
fai navicella top brava brava così giù
giù giù veloce larice la tosta tostapane
stiamo per entrare entro il centro al
buco ma che cazzo fai storici del vice
torta a cazzo e va bene
cazzo vai che c'è entrai che centra mica
solo centro giro nudo per casa il
pomello di merda il pomello di merda il
bravo bravo hyperdrive vai ma cazzo ma
qualche mira di merda che cio che cazzo
ci sono le formiche mutanti nel mio
tosto 6 che ha messo delle formiche
mutanti le formiche e mutanti nel mio
posto c'è un toast sulle mie formiche
mutanti non lo so se il cazzo se ci ha
messo gli anni ma dio mio santone valsa
la pena ragazzi sono entrato non ho
neanche visto quanto ho preso ma
dall'euforia ho cliccato subito
fantastic caccia al formaggio ma che
cazzo non ha seriamente richiamo che
abbiamo aggiunto ste cose non lo trova
tutto il formaggio sono un cracker
bakroman aderenza non casertano fatemi
capire mi devo spalmare la philadelphia
addosso ma il formaggio è questo qua
sopra che puzza è questo qui vieni giù
praia eccoci qua caduto giù pero devo
andare a prendere
vabbè che tanto faccia schifo ma devo
prenderlo cosa hanno capito
l'ho preso l'ho fatta ho la philadelphia
che mi scorre nelle vene non è
filadelfio ragazzi l heller dummer
spalmatelo bene addosso tutto quel
formaggio sei ragazzi sto per fare il
salto le secolo siete pronti non so
quanto possa riuscire mi apro cipro
si passa pure sul pavimento chi se ne
fotte delle impronte per terra che danno
più sapore più gusto dovrebbero fare le
wacko's gusto l'impronta di stivale per
terra provateci ragazzi a prendere le
vostre nike e spalmarle bene bene sui
cracker impossibile certo cosa che cazzo
è successo dio santissimo che pur gas o
degli anni per fast a cagata e tutto per
un pezzo di formaggio scaduto di merda
non importa ragazzi quanti ostacoli
troverete nella vita l'importante è
prendere il formaggio tom e jerry
insegna bello ho preso una lisca di
pesce dio santo quanto voglio questo
cracker non ho mai visto un animale
muoversi così velocemente ma vedo un
crackers che fa di peggio che roba è
veloce
no non ci credo mai non ci credo mai
finire l'aderenza di rimuovere ti devi
muovere devi muoverti è cool
a me era sotto il formaggio al cazzo te
ne vai si no
[Musica]
come allora ragazzi non so in che modo
possa fare questa cosa ma ci provo lo
stesso che cazzo di mira di merda cioè
esattamente qui che volevo finire
credetemi era proprio il lavandino e mio
obiettivo si pro 20mila volte non ci
riesco più a forza cosa ma prendi io sto
formaggio nostre parti come un
deficiente bravo bravo ascolti la
madonna che formaggio di merda
[Musica]
che no mica ecco qua lo stupro di
formaggio e giusto piano pian piano
piano cazzo piano come mi sono salvato
no no ma perché si così rincoglionito
ragazzi cracker piastrelle lavandino
nuova ricetta fa vigente mezz'ora che
tipo vado avanti così dio mio santo
stokr e che era un amen la madonna
sentite che amiamo livello che dite
condividi condividi su facebook
scriviamo porca [ __ ]
ecco perché ora ragazzi manca solo la
corsa del bega e ci avevo fatto l'ultima
volta ma tipo l'ultimo non l'ho fatto
già di jean che l'ultima volta ho fatto
un casino però va bene ha già partito
così mi chiami coda ma come ci si muove
un attimo cazzo ok ok nostra bravo bravo
dai centrati in pieno ai uomo forza
bravo così minchia che polo non nasce
mira che mira al lusso come ho fatto
richiamano l'idea bravissimo che ci fai
drifting che bel sedili in pelle ma
cos'è una lamborghini questa sì
bravissimo mi caricano impossibile già
sto facendo non so come ricordatevi che
i beghe queste ciambelle bellissime sono
più buone col terriccio è una cosa che
vi insegno all'insegna lo zio favi
eccolo che posso essere risucchiato
dagli ufo fantastico fd fa vj ragazzi
ovviamente ci siamo ragazzi manca
l'ultima poi ho finito tutti i livelli e
l'ultimo che mancano mai fatto questo
pompa di benzina è la madonna è un
circuito che cos'è fantastico ragazzo o
ma dopo un parto importante ragazzi e
finirlo ancora sta macchina ma chi è che
mi parcheggia lamborghini e le pompe di
benzina che era un po idiota ma chi è
che la fatte così piccole ok bravo bravo
no ma sei stronzo perfetto bravo zio
bravo complimenti tempo parziale 12 anni
ma va bene è il consiglio così continuo
così bravissimo e poi il resto riesco a
farlo velocemente solo quello che faccio
pagare faretra anche guardando dove sto
andando io vado vado a casa
potrei cadere in burro nioc ecco infatti
che cazzo sto facendo
la votazione così zio bravissimo ecco
perché non sapeva era la fine ovviamente
ci mancava che non cadesse alla fine
victor massiah ragazzi spacchi e ce l'ho
fatta di perfetto ragazzi di v dai cazzo
ma va bene così che bello abbiamo finito
tutti i percorsi questo era l'ultimo in
assoluto bellissima de vito che ho preso
voti diversi in tutti quanti ma me la
fantasia provochi ragazzi concludo qui
l'episodio è stato alquanto strano
rigiocare aim brad ma adesso l'ho finito
non tutto ma solo la modalità l'ho
finita almeno quello è già qualcosa
io spero mi sia piaciuta la serie in
generale su yen pregio perché non so se
farò altri episodi visse a meno che non
facciano aggiornamenti con del
filadelfia per i ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto costruito al momento mi piace
non mi piace se anche voi sotto sotto
fatte le corse con le ciambelle ragazzi
perché io lo so che la mattina prima di
andare a fare colazione vi alzate fate
legale con le ciambelle per far
incazzare la mamma anche la pace di
facebook e con il video tra tardo
tiziano non ce ne vogliano prossimo
video